blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman welcome to the show as some of
you may know the olympics
are being held in japan this year and
china is involved in a genocide against
the uyghur people now you might be
saying david why
why are you telling us two seemingly
unrelated facts japan
olympics china uighur genocide
that makes sense what's the connection
well the connection
is that fox news guest morgan ortegas
on tuesday described the upcoming summer
olympics
in japan as the genocide olympics
apparently confusing japan with china
i mean what the hell right let's take a
look at the clip and what's even more
stunning is
nobody on the panel even corrects her
kaylee mcinanny's on the panel she
doesn't even
nobody corrects it and harris faulkner
says wow
and around these olympics i like to call
them the genocide olympics anyway i'm
i'm still on the team that i'm not even
sure that we should be
competing because there is an ongoing
genocide in xinjiang
so if they're if we are going to go to
kayleigh macanand is actually nodding
if you're if you're not watching
kaylee's nodding about this country if
we are going to compete and have
american athletes there
in a country that's committing a
genocide even more important harris
to have the freedom of the american flag
fully represented
wow says harris faulkner except that's
not what's going on and nobody corrects
morgan ortegas
trump's former white house press
secretary kaylee mcinerney nodding along
this is not a minor mistake you know
which country tends to use
buckwheat noodles this is the topic of
which
country is accused of genocide against a
portion of its own population
japan has no involvement with the
atrocities
and in april um japan actually raised
concerns
about the chinese treatment of the
uyghur muslim minority
now i saw one comment which asked
is it possible that morgan ortegas is
talking about
the beijing olympics of 2022
or could she just be clueless and not
understand that
it's in not in japan but in china that
the weaker genocide is taking place
normally when someone says these
olympics
and the olympics start in a week they're
not talking about some other olympics in
some future year
i don't know i i know that english is my
second language but that's my
understanding of ten what people tend to
say when they say these olympics
and what's really crazy is that ortegas
is a political advisor served as
a state department spokesperson from
2019
to 2021 and she's making this mistake
which gets us of course to
the next question do most fox viewers
know the difference between china and
japan
politically or do they just both sort of
sound like places that are far
that are close to where the so-called
china virus came from and they just
sound like a lot of trouble i don't know
japan china i'm not really sure maybe
this is a perfectly fine analysis on fox
news channel
uh because they don't really distinguish
between these two countries an
absolutely
bizarre segment on fox news and of
course
there are real questions about these
olympics taking place in japan
the questions really relate to the
pandemic
not to the chinese genocide of uyghur
muslims there's also questions around
the olympics about
the role of cannabis as a banned
substance
which is considered equivalent to
performance-enhancing drugs
even though it's not a performance
enhancing drug
and in by by some reports it would sort
of have the opposite effect
anyway the point is there's lots of
issues to discuss related to the
olympics
holding them as japan re-enters covet
guidelines
the role of certain substances and drugs
so many things to discuss uh the
japanese genocide of uyghur muslims is
not one of these things because it's
completely imaginary and fabricated
let's talk about the political football
that is the debt and deficit we've
talked about this piecemeal over the
last several weeks because there have
been continued examples of republicans
talking about how can we afford
all this stuff that joe biden wants
to do when there was no question under
trump about how do we afford anything
and the guy exploded the deficit by
uh significantly uh higher higher
margins than we've seen in a very long
time for any president
it's a political football in the sense
that republicans
claim to have as a guiding principle
fiscal conservatism part of that is
balanced budgets
meaning you spend less than you take in
they also want to change tax law to take
in less and it's really just sort of a
package of trying to
restrict government from really doing
things that's really what's at issue
with republicans anything they can say
to justify government not doing
something not helping people
not being involved in something they
will they will do it but then as soon as
they want to spend money
the concerns about fiscal conservatism
go away this gets
us to two days ago on the neil cavuto
program on fox news
where james lankford james lankford is
not just a republican senator
he's not just a radical extremist
republican senator
something about the guy is really creepy
uh and many of you
have written to me about the same thing
and neil cavuto
good for him every once in a while neil
cavuto does this
neil cavuto calls out james lankford and
says
where were your new concerns about joe
biden spending
when it was donald trump doing that
spending
all right so let's take a look at it
we're going to go piece by piece here
now you might call it socialism senator
um democrats say republicans are fine
ones to start
lecturing on spending of any sort since
debt also piled up in the trump
administration
big packages on paid for filed up in his
administration that was even before
the pandemics so langford starts shaking
his head
and you know he's got something good
coming republicans have
sort of like a leg to stand on yeah of
course we do
they're going back to the 2017 tax cut
and jobs act saying
you cut taxes and you should never cut
taxes you need to raise taxes like we're
planning to do
as they're playing this giant tax
increase if you look at what happened
the tax cut cuts and jobs act
from 2017 we had a rapid expansion of
the number of people getting employed
the number of people actually paying
taxes
okay so so so two things there rapid
expansion of the number of people
employed job creation
was positive in that early area of the
trump uh
um uh first trump's only term so there
were jobs created at the start of
trump's term
at a slower rate than at the end of
barack obama's second term that's number
one so while there was job creation it
was
slower under trump than obama but number
two the job creation did not accelerate
when trump's tax plan was passed
so republicans like to just point and
say
we passed the tax cut plan the tax plan
whatever you want to call it
and jobs continued to be created
the truth is the job creation did not
accelerate and if you
are of the mindset that it was the tax
plan of trump
that created jobs why did job creation
slow down
after that was passed the second piece
is more people employed than ever
this is the labor participation um uh
sort of talking point that they love to
do remember that the united states is a
country whose population keeps growing
so at many times we have a record number
of people working
and a record number of people not
working it's a very deceptive technique
that they will use to their advice i
don't use it because it's deceptive okay
let's continue uh here we go
saw an increase in tax revenue happening
starting in 2019
2020 we had the fastest growing economy
we've had 50 years it's piled up right
and so did the debt i'm not faulting you
for that
i'm just saying that whatever you know
where you boost the economy and that was
clear it did it helped the economy
my point is that the debt piles off that
lecturing
on either parties you know states neil
cavuto's keeping his eye on the ball and
he's saying
you're talking about jobs and you're
talking about revenue aside from the
fact that you're lying about those
things the deficit went up and that
can't be denied
what what is too much money we're beyond
that right now right
well i i get it getting back to balance
is something that needs to be in the
conversation but
okay so anyway neil cavuto pointing it
out and you're not going to get an
answer from james lankford
this this is a really common one and you
know the problem i have with this entire
debt deficit thing is
there's a real conversation to be had
and unfortunately we can't really have
it with these people because they're
just operating in fantasyland the truth
about debt and deficit is complicated
a country's national debt is not
analogous to a household
where hey you know if the income is five
grand a month and expenditures are six
grand a month you're falling behind a
thousand dollars every month
you're either going to start having to
charge and take out
loans to pay that on which you pay
interest and you fall further behind
that's how a household thinks
countries are different and then the the
so so first of all
in terms of what it means to have
national debt relative to
what does it mean to have household debt
not analogous republicans love to
simplify along those lines but more
importantly if a country's economy
is continuing to grow even in evaluating
the level of debt
we need to be looking as debt as a
percentage of gdp
if you have an economy that's growing at
three percent a year
and debt that's growing at two percent a
year you're actually
reducing the significance of that debt
relative
to the size of the economy how
frequently do you hear that discussed
in these conversations about debt and
deficit and then of course
lastly we have to remember that there is
debt that is stimulative
and there i'm sorry you can increase the
deficit now i'm talking about the
deficit you can increase the deficit in
a way that is economically stimulative
and you can increase the deficit in a
way that's not so for example
when you consider the multiplier effect
of food stamps versus rich people
putting
money in a savings account the
stimulative
impact of food stamps which gets spent
they get spent at local businesses
supermarkets
which increases employment but that the
economic multiplier there
is dramatically higher than just a tax
cut for the rich
who mostly save that money because they
don't need that money to fund their
lifestyle
that's another aspect of debt and
deficit where one dollar of deficit is
not always the same thing
the question is what are we getting what
are we financing are we financing the
richest people just
saving a little more money that they
don't spend or are we financing
um some social program with a very high
multiplier effect so
anyway we can't really expect them to
have that conversation they don't care
to because this debt deficit thing is
just a political football and for many
democrats it is as well just on the
opposite side
august 16th is the 16th anniversary of
the david pakman show
it flew by it flew by and we are doing a
one-day membership special i would love
for you to take advantage of it
if you would like to be notified about
this incredible membership special on
august 16th
get a membership i'm sorry get on my
newsletter
at davidpakman.com and on the 16th
you'll get an email telling you how to
sign up for it
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in
15 minutes blinkist makes sure that
you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only
about eight bucks a month and you get
the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
remember that the david pakman show
doesn't have a money tree i've got
eggplants
i've got tomatoes but no money tree in
the backyard
we do depend on the support of viewers
and listeners like you through the
membership program to
support the show you can sign up at
joinpackman.com it would be my pleasure
to welcome you into the ranks of
membership
let's hear from some folks via discord
if you'd like to talk to me the way we
do it is via discord you can
subscribe free to the discord at
davidpakman.com
discord and from that point forward
you will have the opportunity to speak
to me let's do that right now i want to
start today with our caller from atlanta
named
taylor taylor you're on the air what's
on your mind
oh boy hey this is uh david can you hear
me pacman right
yes i can hey great thanks for taking
um well just been mulling over the uh
situation with current events and i'm
just
uh i've been drawing a comparison
between
i guess you know 9 11 and today as both
two big two big events
huge tragedies really to impact us
and just the different responses that
we've had and so back with 911
if you remember those commercials with
you know i'm an american
and it didn't matter who it was
essentially nonpartisan i mean everybody
was behind
um the i guess you could say the the
goal
of whatever the goal was um up until
uh invasion of iraq i'd say
but and then today it's just i mean such
a stark contrast
that we're seeing and and as you've
shown i mean you can draw a line and
it's so partisan now that we have
uh you know something to go against but
it's just so weird how the lines been
drawn
so my question to you as somebody who
covers these types of events
is um the differences between today and
then do you find it
it's more of just the the situation
of what caused it say you know something
i guess maybe tangible as as in the
terrorist attack a threat on safety
versus um you know a virus you can't see
with the naked eye which
is still a threat on safety and we have
like a unified goal
but we're seeing such a different
response to it
yes i i think um that for the most part
this is uh related to uh the sort of
debasing
of actual policy and the move into
cultural issues and as rachel
bittikoffer talked to us about earlier
in the week just um basically focusing
on
optics and talking points and so you
were right
that one might have thought that in a
911 like way
the pandemic might have really united
left and right i mean listen
much like there are pandemic
conspiracies there are also 9 11
conspiracies that's not
different but the degree to which people
were united
in the immediate aftermath of 9 11 uh
seems almost inconceivable today i mean
even attack
attacking doctors you know all of the
stuff exactly exactly
listen i have to ask are you calling
from an aviary
at which construction is taking place
it seems that way uh sitting out back
surrounded by a lot of cardinals right
now
thank you for the call i appreciate it
appreciate it
all right very good um an interesting
one to start with
let's go next to i hope i'm pronouncing
this correctly
is it saurabh from austin texas
uh hi david yeah it's a saurabh
sarub okay great well welcome to the
program
yeah thank you uh i have question
regarding a
homelessness problem that is creeping
across different parts of
the nation majorly cities what would be
the long term and
short-term solutions for homelessness
well
though i think that this is a great
question because the short term and the
long term is different
in the short term we've learned that
it's
cheaper to just pay for housing for
homeless folks and also to pay for
health care for homeless folks now
unfortunately
if you're like a right wing moral
majority type
person you would say well they don't
deserve
that they haven't earned that but
there's numerous studies that show
the societal cost in terms of
having people on the streets
uninsured visits to the emergency room
uh police calls etc it's cheaper to just
house
people now that's not really a long-term
solution necessarily i think on the
longer term
we really have to look at uh either
government jobs programs
universal basic income um uh in some
cases it's about minimum wage
it's about economic restructurings you
know it's about a lot of bigger things
that take a
much longer time uh that's how i would
distinguish between the short term and
the long term on homelessness
okay thank you my pleasure thank you for
the call yeah did you have something
else
and thank you for being out there and
representing not just my hair type but
also my hairstyle
oh beautiful yeah i don't even what is
the name of the hairstyle
i i don't know it's just woke up and
a little bit of comb very good exactly i
think that's gonna work
just woke up and a little bit of comb
all right thank you uh saurabh i
appreciate it yeah
all right very good beautiful phone call
let's go next to alex from orange county
hey david can you hear me yes i can
um so um have you covered what's going
on in texas and texas
democrats we covered it on the wednesday
bonus show yeah it's crazy basically
i'll explain to people who don't know
just real quick before you get to your
question um
texas republicans want to pass
restrictive voting rights
texas democrats don't have a majority
and so their idea was prevent a quorum
texas republicans said we're going to
have state troopers drag you in
so texas democrats left the state and
texas republicans want state troopers
to leave texas and to drag democrats
back
um so my question is do you feel like
the democrats
efforts are futile do you feel like
you're just
i mean listen you don't have the
majority
eventually they're almost certainly
going to get a vote on this
but i do think that given this
and given the toxic and corrosive and
disenfranchising nature of the
the voting restrictions that i like
democrats doing what they can to delay
it
and showing the crazy lengths to which
republicans are willing to go to dr
drag them back but i do think ultimately
they're going to get a vote
so what needs to be changed do you think
do they need a a democratic
um i'm sorry did you say a democratic
majority you cut out
a democratic governor like um some like
democratic leadership
like actually yeah i mean so listen the
first thing would be for texas to be run
by a governor and state legislature
laters that don't want to do this crazy
stuff that would be step one
the other idea would be to really have
super strong
federal um uh limitations on what states
are allowed to do in terms of voting
rights that would be the other way to
prevent this from being an issue
all right um interesting thank you david
and thank you for taking my call
my pleasure thank you for calling in a
very very
um important uh question
and one that is very very relevant right
now why don't we
speak next wow the phone lines are just
packed we might need to widen
the discord tubes in order to allow more
people in
why don't we go next to michael
from is it baco or bakko
ah yes can you hear me yes i can yeah
it's it's bakersfield to short for
bakersfield oh i didn't know that was a
nickname for bakersfield it's like it's
like a nickname yeah
so my name is michael um yeah so my
question is
have you ever considered um run like for
future like have you considered running
for president like 2024
i am not eligible to be president due to
not being born in the united states
okay understood gotcha okay well that
was my question uh thank you
have a great day i mean i'm still
considering it i just legally can't be
president so i don't know
what if what if they what if they ever
change it then i will absolutely be
there
perfect thank you have a great day now
that's a perfect phone call if i've ever
heard one
let's go next to vega from oklahoma
hey david how's it going it's going well
thank you
um so i was watching the texas democrats
yesterday and honestly it's very
exciting that they got to go over to
washington d.c
yeah yeah so um
what do you think about progress on the
voting rights legislation like hr1 and
hr4 and also the infrastructure package
they just revealed the
3.5 trillion dollar package today
yeah so on the on voting rights i'm not
hugely optimistic about the bill i've uh
this has been my view for some time and
as as i'm sure you know vega
i would immediately change my opinion if
the facts changed that's just the type
of guy i
am i'm not very optimistic on the voting
rights act
on infrastructure i am more optimistic i
think joe biden desperately needs
another major accomplishment and uh i'm
hoping that it is going to
um that it is going to happen hello
yes you're on the air okay oh
sorry sorry your voice went out for a
sec
all right vega thank you very much for
the call i appreciate it a lot of
important questions
today and glad to have the opportunity
to answer them
let's go next to oh i don't know
how about daniel from california also
known as rue
new grungler oh hello david
hello uh yes so like my username
nug wrangler suggests i'm going to be
blunt
so when is aoc going to be on the show
i know the possibility was teased last
year shortly after
winning the race to a million
subscribers anytime she wants it's wide
open
we've uh we've reached out a couple of
times and haven't heard back she may be
too big for this show right i'm not
delusional
uh but she's welcome absolutely anytime
yeah yeah definitely definitely big um
you know well
you're a good interview interviewer so
i'm sure you'd have an eloquent way of
asking her
how she juggles idealism with
pragmatism and i also wanted to know
what she
would have would have thought of my
prediction worthless prediction
that it will be aoc versus ivanka in
2024.
um it will not be aoc versus ivanka in
2024
but i will make a note of it and ask her
about in some way i guess if she's ever
on the show
yeah well you know i'm a gambler i i you
know i roll the dice so
that's my bet are you actually betting
on that i mean you could probably get
action on that if you really felt that
was going to happen
you probably got a thousand to one odds
yeah
i'm paying a a membership
okay all right very good with uh illegal
discount codes
so it's affordable thank you i
appreciate that
all right thanks for taking my call all
right thanks very much um
listen i'm gonna tell you right now be
very careful with those discount codes i
don't want anybody ending up in prison
as a result of them
why don't we go next to
um let's go to nick from florida
nick you're on the air hello um sorry if
the mic's bad
uh i just wanted to ask uh
i care about the environment and there's
this one thing where
people are buying like exotic pets down
here
and i wanted to get like a piece of
legislation
or legislation to make it so that it's
not as common
or is that like people are disencouraged
in doing that without getting like a
license
is there anything i can do i want to
like get a start in doing
beautiful yeah start with your local
officials so i would i would start with
i mean you know i don't know if you can
if it would that that has to be i don't
know enough about exotic pet laws to
know
they're probably state level but maybe
some of this stuff is municipality
i would start with mayor city
councillors state rep
state senator governor's office right to
all of them and
and uh see if anybody is willing to work
with you on that but that's exactly i
mean you have a specific idea
this is what our legislators are
supposed to be there for reach out to
all of them directly and see who will
listen to you
okay one more thing you're a godsend
whenever you interrupt destiny's league
streams
oh okay well i will i will try to do
would you mean interrupt by going
by on oh by hopping on oh
yeah well i'll try to keep doing it then
thank you all right very good uh yeah
those exotic pets that's bad news folks
that's really really bad news um
okay a lot of people you know sometimes
i think like
okay people get banned on twitter people
get banned on youtube and stuff like
that but like even now during calls
people are getting banned on our discord
and there's a bunch more that are about
to get banned it's crazy what people are
able to do
let's go next to sd from dallas texas
you're on the air
hello david how are you i am doing well
what a pleasure uh the pleasure is all
mine i didn't expect this one to sleep
so um oh hello
so uh on yesterday's show um you covered
these massive protests like these
unprecedented protests
going on in um cuba and
i know they're multifaceted like there
may not be like a single thing
everyone's pointing to
that everyone puts the blame but
uh a lot of our cuban american friends
and
especially in the greater miami area
have raised the call for intervention
of some sorts yeah what if any kind of
intervention would you support
so um we talk so one of the people is
actually the mayor
of miami who did that whose father was
also the first cuban
american mayor of miami um they're
talking about military intervention so
i'm completely opposed to military
intervention i i think basically what
needs to happen in in cuba
is um oh you got what you got a dog
there
uh no i'm walking oh right now it
sounded like a dog bark sorry
um we i my preference would be
as someone so so just for context
i'm an anti-authoritarian progressive so
of course i'm against the cuban regime
fidel castro coming to power in 1959
remaining in power until 2008
uh then handing power to his brother
right there's nothing progressive about
that as a progressive
i have to be against that i'm also
against the american embargo of cuba
and i think that that primarily really
hurts the cuban people
it's not gotten cuba to change their
system of government which
supposedly was was what it was intended
to pressure them to do
so what i would like to see in terms of
cuba is i would
like to do away with the american
embargo
and to then work in a global coalition
to encourage cuba to hold elections
and to not be authoritarian but and this
is a big but
it can't be that the us is in any way
involved in the election or runs a
candidate or any of that stuff
that so we have to be able to draw clear
lines i am not for
american intervention in a cuban
election but what i would love to see is
for us to get off of the hypocrisy of
the cuban embargo
start to send aid and do more things to
help the cuban people and work with a
diverse
i mean listen even you know uh we're
hearing from
world leaders about it's time for cuba
uh to actually have real elections
and that that would be my preference
yeah um i i kind of see what you're
going with there
um i am in terms of lifting the embargo
i'm absolutely on board with uh
returning free enterprise to the island
yep um but uh
i i think we have to be a little
cautious because like we see this with a
lot of countries that were once
authoritarian is that authoritarian
development is now a new trend on the
rise so
i don't know if only permitting free
enterprise is necessarily
going to turn the island into uh the
liberal democracy we all want to see oh
i totally agree with you no it won't and
in fact it's important to understand a
lot of the new authoritarianism
including these parties in europe for
example
it's very what's going on in cuba again
it's been since 59 it's a totally
different animal what's going on there
and the approach needs to be different i
agree with you
yeah yeah yeah and uh for record like
there are
like there has been um a regime in exile
here in the united states i shouldn't
say regime like the
cuban government in exile here in the
united states
um that sort of like a lot of people
looking to free cuba look up to
uh so i couldn't possibly comment on
that
i could i don't know if they're
right-wing authoritarians or i don't i
don't know any i couldn't possibly
comment on that i have no knowledge of
what their perspective is
okay david i'll leave you there thank
you for taking my call all right my
pleasure yeah
yeah i want to be if i don't know about
something i just can't comment
you know government and exile that could
be anything that they could be
whatever um okay let's take a quick
break
if you're holding don't hang up because
we're going right back to the phone
lines momentarily
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials
you also get access to our entire
archive
of every episode dating back a really
long time
and plenty of other awesome membership
perks go to joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21
for a huge discount join pacman.com
alright let's hear from a few more
people in the david pakman show audience
we take
calls via discord you can find that at
davidpakman.com
slash discord why don't we go
first in this segment to meg
b meg b you were on the air
hi can you hear me yes i can oh my gosh
i can't believe i'm talking to you okay
i can't believe i'm talking to you meg
oh my gosh okay my husband's gonna freak
okay
so um i really have a big question about
the march for medicare for all because i
don't know any
that i saw it on the humanness report
and so i got excited about it and then
all of a sudden i looked it up more and
there are all these controversies about
neo-nazis
organizing it and gathering information
and so i keep on trying to get more
information on it and no one
is giving us information and so my
husband uh
reserved a hotel in austin and so then
he's like are we gonna you know go to it
or what
and i said i don't know because i can't
get more information
i'm really you know nervous because i
trust the humanist report
but um i don't really see anyone else
covering it so
i have to tell you i don't know a thing
about
this is a a texas march for medicare for
all
well no it's a um it's national and it's
in uh i think it's like in 30 different
states or something like that and so
that and when is it taking place
uh june 24th which is supposed to be the
birthday of medicare
but that june of 2022 no june
uh july 24th
oh i i i just don't know anything about
it you know with with all of the
i don't really go anywhere um and
i'm trying to avoid big crowds so i i
couldn't i really couldn't tell you
anything about it it strikes me as un
implausible that neo-nazis are
organizing it but
it's certainly it's certainly plausible
that neo-nazis are infiltrating it i
really don't know a thing about it
i couldn't i wouldn't say but i you know
what i appreciate is
that you're even asking these questions
because a lot of people end up at events
they don't even understand so i like
that you're
you're investigating this okay well i
really appreciate it and i've been
watching you for years and years and
years so thank you so much for
taking my call my pleasure i'm glad to
have spoken to you today
thanks all right say hi to your husband
for me beautiful
okay perfect phone call really perfect
phone call
a beautiful call the likes of which
we've only read about
why don't we go next i'm hoping i hope i
pronounce this correctly is it kuma
from china yep
can you hear me tip it i can hear you
fine
okay thank you um so i'm a chinese
immigrant who
currently lives in canada oh i don't i
still don't like
i still don't speak perfect english so
please bear with me no you're doing
great
you're doing great um so the other day i
read this quote
from roger skooten it goes something
like
conservatism starts from the sentiment
that
good things are easily destroyed but
not easily created so my mom is a very
interesting case when i
think about this she's against
everything that has been going on in
china
for the last few decades um
her family were victims of the cultural
revolution
yes she wants more democracy human
rights protection you know
checks and balances for the government
so i guess in that
in that sense she is a progressive
but when it comes to u.s politics um
she's a huge
trump supporter because trump is very
hard on china
and i guess she's just a bit you know
traumatized by
socialist ideologies because the chinese
government has never really put it off
and has done a lot of bad things under
the name of
socialism um so she would be a
conservative if she were
in the u.s today and i can speak the
same for
most of chinese immigrants of her age
and you
in the u.s interesting yeah so my
question is
how much conservatism in the u.s do you
think
comes from the sentiment that things are
generally good and we should
not rush to change it versus you know
the action policies or
ideas like in my mom's case so i think
there's two
there's actually there are numerous
immigrant populations that are
that tend to be conservative or at least
are frequently conservative
one is as you're talking about chinese
immigrants of a certain age
who are really only conservative in in
one sense as you're pointing out but at
the same time
sort of have what we might consider more
of a leftist critique
against the chinese regime of the
cultural revolution that's one group
we've also talked about certain latin
american immigrants in particular cuban
americans
some venezuelans and then also there are
some centrist south and latin americans
who just kind of end up voting for
moderate republicans because they see
them as sort of like
as you're pointing out exactly they're
like things are better in the us than
they were where i came from
and it feels like those moderate
republicans are sort of trying to keep
things in that way they're not on board
with like the radical right stuff but
they're just like i'm kind of a moderate
conservative
um and then you also have uh another
group is there's
surprisingly high number of eastern
europeans
including russians and others um
who tend to surprise me often when they
when i learn that they are actually
pro-trump and
i think that there's a couple different
things one aspect
is they uh see
american republicanism as the opposite
of what they abandoned in their country
rightly or wrongly and therefore they
just sort of gravitate towards it that's
one piece of it the other piece of it is
exactly what you're saying which is
the idea that if you think things are
sort of pretty good
um then sometimes you say well let's
keep things the way they are and
conservatism by definition wants to
conserve that so
yeah i think your analysis is good and i
think there's even you know more to it
okay thank you so much my pleasure thank
you for the call that's
that's an interesting topic i like this
one let's speak to a couple of other
people why not
right i mean we're doing it we might as
well let's talk to
how about tom from boston tom from
boston you're on the air
how's it going david going well um
so a couple weeks ago you had we're
talking about needing like a mass
deprogramming for
you know the conspiratorial thinkers and
the hardcore trumpers
yeah um and then last week we mentioned
that you were reading going clear and it
got me thinking that i
really don't think that a master
programming
is very likely i agree with you i think
i think we're much more likely to see a
scientology type situation where it's
just slowly chipped away at i think that
it's possible that if more of trump's
records come out during this whole
you know case with his company um
that could do some damage but i really
think you're just going to see all of
these groups that kind of came together
to support him splinter off
yeah i mean the thing about that is
scientology
you know 74 million people voted for
trump um
scientology at its peak was a fraction
of a fraction of a fraction of that
very true we could be talking about if
we're just do if we're doing that
we could have to we might have to wait
two thousand years right so i i think
i guess that is true but there are a lot
of um
a lot of comparisons you can draw there
are pretty legendary con men
it's actually crazy in reading so what
what tom is talking about is that i
mentioned i'm reading lawrence wright's
sort of profile of the history of
scientology and l ron hubbard called
going clear
and in reading it the way people kind of
got sucked in is very trumpian
l ron hubbard himself is very trumpy and
it's super interesting to read because
it's so analogous to trump trumpism
um yeah i mean i think i think you're
right nasty programming is difficult one
of the most efficient ways to mask the
program
is with a completely authoritarian
takeover
right but that's bad that's a bad way to
deep because
all you're really doing is you're
reprogramming
exactly right you're just reprogramming
into something else in
an equally authoritarian way so it's
tough yeah as i said i don't really have
a solution but
your solution likely is sensible it'll
just take a really really really long
time
unfortunately yeah i don't think we're i
don't think it's going to be a quick
thing
no no by no means all right well thanks
and if you haven't read lawrence
wright's um
uh the looming tower definitely give
that a read oh what's that one
that's his um his history of al qaeda
and the lead up to 911.
oh okay i'll check that out i recently
read his name it's a pulitzer winner
he wrote a novel a pandemic novel called
the end of october
and i recently read that as well yeah
it's really we'll have to check that out
yeah he's quite good
he's very good very good all right tom
thank you all right thank you
very good um calls about books i mean
guys what more can you ask for right
it's just an incredible day here
let's go to brian from gainesville
georgia today
hi david glad you're doing well thank
you so
it seems like we're on the verge of more
um
uh mass hospitalizations uh from this
delta variance
we may be we may be georgia
especially here in georgia so i i guess
my question is
uh since vaccinated people for the most
part have largely
kind of returned to mostly returned to
normal we're starting to go into movie
theaters now
even um what
i hate to even suggest this but should
at some point
hospitals consider prioritizing
uh for example when uh somebody gets
into a
really bad car accident and they need
instant medical attention versus
somebody who's unvaccinated
and needs medical attention i i just i
just i feel like that
because of the wave of uh the the new
coronavirus wave that's coming through
that the hospitals are just going to get
possibly even more overwhelmed
than when we first went into lockdown
and
i don't think it'll get that bad because
there are a lot of people vaccinated who
are very unlikely to get the virus
and if they do they're very unlikely to
be symptomatic and if they are they're
very unlikely to be hospitalized
so i think it's not going to get that
bad i do think it's going to get bad
particularly among the unvaccinated
population but what you're suggesting is
complicated because
so like what's on the fundamental of
what you're saying correct me if i'm
wrong
is not getting vaccinated is an
irresponsible action
so therefore if you need medical
attention as a result of that
you should be lower priority more or
less that's what you're saying right
that's what i'm i i don't
i don't know if that's what should be
done i'm just
no no
i don't think so and the reason why is
we know
riding a motorcycle is really dangerous
compared to driving in a car
would we say people in motorcycle
accidents should be de-prioritized from
car accidents
no no people wouldn't say that we know
that
smoking is a self-destructive and and
negative to your health activity
does that mean if you smoke and you go
and you have i don't know a pulmonary
embolism i don't even know if smoking
can cause that but some lung thing
acute you go to the emergency room and
they go sorry
the kid who broke his ankle gets
priority
because the the kid doesn't smoke the
kid was just playing basketball or
something
it just it just would you know hospitals
have a duty to treat and they have
triage protocols and i i just i know
what you're saying which is
it's such an easy thing you just go get
vaccinated you reduce the chances of
clogging up the medical system
i just don't think in practice it's
gonna it's really something that can be
done
i see i see and i think i think you're
right i don't
i don't think it will get that bad but
i'm also looking at this from this
perspective of like for example when we
went into lockdown
yep uh a lot of us stayed home we were
off the roads
uh we uh didn't uh you know that
helped with uh that helped to some
extent with
uh with car crashes yeah uh which
like so i'm a traffic engineer for
example so i see
uh i have seen throughout this year the
uh
even though there were fewer cars on the
road uh
there was an increase in uh there was an
increase particularly in deaths
yeah per capita per capita car accident
death yeah
yes indeed uh so i noticed that and i
think some of that is possibly due to
you know okay there's fewer people on
the road so people feel more comfortable
driving at higher speeds
and that's when those collisions take
place absolutely
that's the that's the theory i mean it's
the same thing like
if you were driving irresponsibly fast
so we're going to treat the person with
the headache first it's like it just
doesn't work that way that's not the way
our system works
yeah indeed but a very very important
topic and i appreciate you bringing it
up
thank you david all right thank you very
much all right guys
excellent topics today for the most part
that does it for calls today
we're going to take a quick break we'll
be back with more show today
and we will take calls again fear not
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon
go to patreon.com david pakman show
where you can get access to behind the
scenes videos
the daily bonus show the commercial free
daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as
two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com
davidpakmanshow okay let's get into
audience questions for the week some
some good ones i must say i'm impressed
with the audience first question david
what happens to drug
trafficking uh and the illegal drug
trade if
all drugs are decriminalized or
legalized so these are really two
questions
what happens to drug trafficking with
decriminalization
is very different than what happens to
drug trafficking with legalization
so if we just see decriminalization of
drugs
in terms of possession you're not going
to see a drastic change to trafficking
in that case
the cartels won't really need to change
anything in order to continue being
profitable
operationally i don't think that they
would see any
anything major change but you would
start to maybe see some changes when it
comes to american institutions
maybe at the prison level you would see
some differences although i don't think
they would be as big as some people
think i'm going to get back to that
um you would probably see
more people suffering from addiction
willing to go and seek treatment
because of this word decriminalization
it's no longer a
criminal thing but i think for the most
part
from a dealer standpoint from a cartel
standpoint
from a gang standpoint and we know about
the overlap between drugs drugs and
gangs
you would see operating you would see
them operating basically the same way
they do
um although maybe they would
shift a little bit to areas where
you could leverage something that is
still
completely criminal rather than
decriminalized but still not
really okay um and remember that
when we talk about decriminalization and
legalization
we're talking about possession for use
and the idea of um
when even in cases of legalization you
still need to be licensed
i mean look at cigarettes as an example
cigarettes which are
legal um you still see a black market
for cigarettes and you still see
people trying to pay less for them by
going
uh obtaining them in ways other than the
way that
the government has established through
regulation should be done
now if you actually saw legalization
i think that that would take a big bite
out of the black market i think you
would see if there was really full
legalization
where state government or federal
government or both says as has been done
with cannabis in a lot of places already
this is now legal as long as you're
licensed to produce
and sell it there are some limits in
terms of how much any individual can
have
or grow and you need to be 21 and you
need to be paying taxes in this way and
that type of thing
you would still have a black market
which would likely be cheaper and you
still
see that but it might actually impact
the level of violence to some degree
you you i think that you would actually
see a decrease
in the amount of violence but it would
be less violence related to the
production and distribution of that
substance you would still have gangs and
cartels
my expectation would be if you legalize
more and more drugs
you'd see gangs and cartels go in the
direction of
human trafficking uh organ trafficking
extortion kidnapping protection and the
sort of example or model for that
is look at the united states during
alcohol prohibition in the early 20th
century
um it created a different
uh uh criminal world and then when it
was
re-legalized it's not like criminality
went away
it was a switch we've seen uh mafias
switch from uh and to you know
from alcohol to gambling or
prostitution or whatever the case may be
so
then let's talk about the prison thing
with decriminalization
of personal use amounts alone
i actually am not sure that american
prison populations would dramatically
decrease and what i mean by that is the
following
yes some people do end up in prison
simply for possession of personal use
uh drugs for the most part like
overwhelmingly
people that are imprisoned for drugs are
in prison
because they either were involved in
uh the trade and had amounts that are
far
bigger than what would be decriminalized
or legalized
and what we're seeing already at the
state level bears this out
or it's drugs connected to other
crimes as well so i think if you
were to legalize decriminalize and say
everybody
in prison simply for a personal
possession drug charge is being let out
the u.s would still be very very high in
terms of per capita and
incarceration globally and i don't know
that simply decriminalizing or
legalizing personal use amounts
is actually going to be the big
improvement from a criminal justice
standpoint as some people believe that
it's going to be those are the numbers i
found
if you disagree let me know hey david
what with
republican anti-vaxxerism when will
kovid become a republican virus
this is we've talked about this a little
bit increasingly
covid is already becoming a more and
more republican virus and in the united
states
what do we know we know that um last
month for example
99 of those who died of the coronavirus
were unvaccinated
not a hundred percent but ninety-nine
percent
when you look at the twenty percent of
the country that doesn't wanna get
vaccinated
it's overwhelmingly republican somewhere
between forty three and fifty percent of
republicans don't want to get vaccinated
whereas most independents do and almost
every democrat
wants to get or has gotten vaccinated so
you've got this big gap
in vaccination by political affiliation
by party
and overwhelmingly the people that are
dying of the virus
now are people that are unvaccinated so
i believe that
it already is to some degree and
very soon will be even more of a
republican virus
now the question that some people have
been writing in with is a slightly
different question
which is uh is it possible that
by virtue of republicans not getting
vaccinated
and the virus over time killing more
republicans that it will actually have
an electoral impact
because more republicans than democrats
will die and therefore democrats will
win
more elections probably not probably not
um there's a couple different things
here first of all
when you look at the number of votes you
know joe biden got 80 million donald
trump got 74
million that's 154 million votes right
there
kovit has tragically killed more than
600 000
people fortunately that number
is low relative to the voting population
that i mean maybe there's some local
races
where if it's a really red county
and it's really like almost all
republicans who die from covet over the
next
you know year whatever up until the 2022
election maybe there's like a local race
where it could make a difference
but big picture i don't expect that that
is actually going to make an electoral
difference the other thing that you have
to remember is
uh republic one of the things that we we
know from early in the virus
that contributes to spread in people
getting sick is population density
and because democrats more than
republicans like to live in cities and
because cities and urban areas tend to
be more democratic
that's a structural disadvantage when it
comes to
virus deaths for democrats relative to
republicans so
i think increasingly this is going to be
a republican virus i don't think
it's going to have electoral
consequences but if you disagree with my
very rough kind of back of the envelope
math on it uh certainly let me know
david is it possible that running trump
in 2024
could actually be a disaster for the
republican party yeah i mean listen
if they lose it's bad a lot of this
stuff is figured out in retrospect
um if if trump runs in 24 and loses
then yeah it's bad if trump runs in 24
and wins
then it's good by definition because
they won but
i think that the the better lens through
which we should view it is
even republicans who don't like trump
agree that having trump for four years
was better than having hillary
and when you understand that you get a
sense of the reality
that even if i mean listen trump 2016
was a disaster for the republican party
trump won
they lost the house in 2018 they lost
the senate in 2020
they lost the white house in 2020 2022
to be determined how they do so
it was a disaster to run trump and yet
the republican party is still mostly
united
they're overwhelmingly behind donald
trump
two-thirds of them say they would follow
donald trump to a third party
if that's what it came down to in order
to keep supporting donald trump
so there's a reason that the republican
party continues to embrace him big
picture
despite the fact that he lost everything
for them and it's become really really
clear over the last
uh okay five years ten years even
really starting with the bush era
although during the obama
phase it really kicked up republicans
have given up on policy
and you know oh we're about fiscal
conservatism no they criticize the
budget as a political cudgel they use it
as a cudgel
but then when their guy blows up the
budget they don't say a word about it
they say support the troops except when
they don't then they say support the
police except when they don't
all of this stuff is bogus they've given
up on policy
given that now the republican party has
decided that they're basically going to
be
a you know meme and own the left
type party focused on talking about
communism and socialism and this type of
thing in a sense trump's a good
candidate for that
because trump number one brought in
people who don't care about policy and
never did and weren't engaged in
politics and for
the first time they paid attention
because they liked the idea
of how trump talked and the fact that it
wasn't about policy it was just about
meaning essentially trolling
in some sense um and even establishment
republicans who may not like that
realize well if it's trump or hillary 99
of us still prefer donald trump so when
we say could 2024 be a disaster for the
republican party
it could be bad for them and that they
might lose and they might lose really
really bad like they did in 2018 and
2020. but as far as
fracturing and destroying the republican
party if anything has been proven
uh over the last four months i guess or
you know six since the election or wait
how many has it been no it's been uh
eight months since the election that's
crazy if anything has been proven
it's that even when they lose
republicans still seem very united that
even a mediocre candidate as they may
see trump some of them
is better than hillary it's better than
joe biden and so from that standpoint
i don't think it will be terrible for
republicans to run trump in 2024. you
know what if he loses
they'll be energized again the way many
of them are energized right now
if you disagree with me send me your
thoughts
also make sure that you are signed up at
joinpakman.com
so that you get access to the bonus show
on which today
we will be discussing many exciting and
important stories
we will see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman